we're learning more tonight about the
massive ransomware attack being blamed
on a now familiar group of hackers from
russia
experts say this may be the largest such
operation ever
national security correspondent jennifer
griffin tells us about it tonight from
the pentagon
we're getting more detail and
information but that's what i can tell
you now
our evil the same russian cyber gang
that fleeced the largest meat supplier
in the world for 11 million dollars last
month
is thought by cyber security experts to
be responsible for the latest ransomware
attack
it appears to have caused minimal damage
to u.s
businesses but we're still gathering
information while visiting michigan this
weekend president biden ordered his
national security team to determine if
there are links to the kremlin
if it is either with the knowledge of
and or
a consequence of russia then i told
putin we will respond
cyber experts from the u.s and russia
plan to meet next week
the ransomware attack carried out
through software from the miami-based
firm cassaya
comes just weeks after biden met russian
president vladimir putin in geneva
sweden was among the hardest hit with
cash registers at a large grocery store
chain locked for the past three days
in a message posted on the dark web the
criminals offered the decipher key
to the thousands of companies affected
across 17 countries
for a mere 70 million dollars in
cryptocurrency ransom i read somewhere
someone said this is the most the
largest
attack in history i mean this is it is
nothing like that
but it has my name on it has our
company's name on it
and you know it's we're embarrassed and
we're doing everything we can to fix it
the white house reminded private sector
companies about their responsibility in
upgrading their cyber security we are
going to continue to be partners
because it's important to protect our
critical infrastructure
but also to ensure that impacts on
smaller businesses on mom and pop shops
are
are minimized as well this attack we are
told was not the result of a phishing
email but more sophisticated using
backdoor holes in it infrastructure
the national security council will meet
tomorrow to discuss
a response mike jennifer griffin live at
the pentagon jennifer
many thanks hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else